[Music]
foreign
parties and really only because of the
half-baked movies and sitcom episodes
they Inspire also I'm already irritated
about the future conversation
surrounding whether or not the boys is a
Christmas show oh oh Mary Merry
Christmas Tran Lu Santa Claus easy tiger
I want you in the a game assuming a man
can't be on their a game because they
drink too much alcohol and while you're
probably right it still hurts our
feelings homelander is busy saving lives
which is interesting considering we've
already seen at least four of the seven
at this Christmas party not saving any
lives I'm not saying they can't have
time off but isn't it a little
irresponsible to have three superheroes
be in the Deep Off Duty at the same time
using tiny cursive writing on your name
badges the whole point is to make
introductions less awkward and you're
hardly going to accomplish that by
forcing me to squint stare a few inches
above everyone's left nipple before
saying hello
all smashed up again butcher would be
excellent in wetsuit since man Huey
didn't learn a single thing from Seth's
cautionary tale did he after Robin
programming other people's remotes it
felt kind of pointless yeah but most
people don't require a live-action
pureeing of their partner to realize
this these incredibly high definition
pictures are not the work of a little 85
camera I put in my doorbell casing so
take that hard-working and underpaid
continuity people don't worry everyone
will forget all about it when we get to
the Gill scene to have a hero like you
in a place like Sandusky yay we're
carrying on with the Deep's very shallow
B plot so glad we're doing this instead
of spending more time with Frenchie
kamiko Queen Maeve black noir or you
know just making these episodes 10
minutes shorter trying to type with
gloves on also I've never understood why
these soups just stay in their costumes
24 7. I get they don't really have
secret identities but they do own other
clothing right
the more I see it the angrier I get stop
showing us people vomiting especially
with zero [__] warning you
low-hanging fruit grabbing rap bastard
biscuits not you Noir you've been great
having a character telling us another
character is doing great work even
though we as the viewers have seen none
of that great work being done we get 37
subplots about how creepy the deep is
but so far we get none of the Noir
kicking ass goodness that I'm so here
for I just can't help noticing that it
all started when you came along if you
my position what would you do to you I'm
sure there's nothing homelander enjoys
more than swinging his around but what
good does exposing Starlight do right
now if he thinks she's working with the
boys why not use her to draw them out or
trap them she didn't know wow
stinks of adrenaline in her hearts
beating like a little rabbit no sh
Captain murder boner you try staring
down the barrel of a sociopathic
Superman and see how dry your panties
are after The Experience oh no you don't
stir you fold
like this backseat cooking I don't think
I can do this anymore I know the power
of a recently relieved boner can provide
a certain amount of Love fog but does
Huey really think he can walk away from
this he pulled the trigger on
translucent's last colonoscopy is one of
the few people who know about compound V
and is now expecting to start a life not
just with a soup but a member of the
seven he's so deep in this the only way
he walks away is if DC buys the rights
to the comics and James Gunn
retroactively unfucks his life in the
flashpoint movie I mean why not it's
apparently gonna fix everything else
better to be loyal to a dead woman who
doesn't know and doesn't care how's that
working out for you oh and I mean every
syllable of what I'm about to say Huey
survives this he's fine Remington steals
almost time I know Adrian is saying this
in jest but this is Remington [__]
steal you're talking about a train the
only negative thing about Remington
steel is that no one is bothered to give
us a Blu-ray set of the complete series
my place is burned they've got me
butcher has a camera in his apartment
that's linked to his phone and how many
of those apps don't all also come with
some sort of alarm that tells you when
someone breaks in what's the point of
only finding out after the [__]
break-in has happened also I'm not sure
what button I'm supposed to believe
butcher pressed here but I don't see
anything on his phone that looks like a
home security app get your ass over here
in 20 minutes I'm gonna burst something
like a [__] pinata so you're gonna
blindly run around hoping you hit the
target without hospitalizing too many
kids in the process feels inefficient
but it's your party dude
why is a train wasting his super speed
in this apartment how far away could
Huey's room possibly be special 2016
Comic-Con Edition
Huey still has these call me sentimental
but I think the discarding slash burning
slash voodooing of the action figures
are the person who turned my partner
into chunky human Chutney what happened
almost immediately I am not leaving you
with him all right you're just a kid
you're my kid imagine having Simon
[__] peg in your show and you just
use him to spout off repetitive dialogue
like this
I'll be all right I got this you really
shouldn't Huey but somehow you do and
I'm not buying any of it I was drawing
you a picture you were can I see oh my
goodness this is beautiful lying I'm
telling you you're gonna love it here
telling someone that Ohio is a place to
love living way back
said late okay we'd be totally remiss if
we didn't address the infamous nightmare
fuel that is the Gill scene I think I
see what the show's doing and I'm all
for addressing the fact that men can be
victims too but I'm not sure I'm on
board with the idea of this being some
sort of karmic payback or a baby step
towards a Redemptive Arc for the deep it
shouldn't take an eye for an eye
situation for him to realize that what
he did to Starlight and who knows how
many other women was wrong either way
here's a sin for just being gratuitously
[__] gross
looks like butcher recently graduated
from the Michael Myers School of chasing
your victims how did you stuck a little
bug on you wow good thing this is
mesmer's lucky jacket that he never
leaves the house without but also never
cleans folds or uses any of its Pockets
also episode expects us to believe that
a New York airport bathroom would ever
be completely unoccupied and I do not
believe you Mesmer gets pulled to his
feet by a broken wrist and doesn't
scream ow that's my broken [__] wrist
you [__] Dunder schmuck now we don't
know the circumstances of how Becca left
that office but it does seem strange
that homelander wouldn't think that her
leaving in this day wouldn't look
suspicious to the camera that he must
know is there okay maybe we can chalk
this up to homelanders Reckless and so
powerful that he doesn't give a sh but
that just makes me question why he cares
about anything at all oh no no no not
that one
this one yeah that's my guy because [__]
all these other lobsters that apparently
don't deserve to live you excuse me
Uncle Billy asking a kid to call you
Uncle when you are not in fact their
Uncle don't say sorry no I look at you
standing up for yourself and murdering
people don't forget the murdering part
Hugh senior so what are these uh pets no
just breeding I try not to get too
attached to my subjects heavy-handed
metaphors also owning dogs for the sole
purpose of breeding them you're one step
away from a puppy mill sir and that's
getting you all the [__] since you
want to know about Rebecca butcher you
want to Stilwell about her because you
knew that'd tip over the first Domino
well it led to me are we missing a
[__] scene here how did homelander
get from Stillwell to vogelbomb what
[__] Domino did he listen in on
Stillwell warning him why would
homelander assume that vogelbomb had
anything to do with Rebecca based on
what was said was still well at this
point he has no idea that she was
pregnant she's just a missing person
forgiveness now after you raise me like
a [__] lab rat holy [__] Anthony
Stars so [__] good his homelander I
almost feel sorry for him here almost no
homelander we had a deal everyone else
is fair game I still don't understand
how not going after homelander is going
to make a [__] difference do they
really believe that homelander will
happily sit back as the mud people go
after all of VOD and every other soup if
they're that afraid of homelander they
should also be afraid of Vaught
are you okay nope not doing it not even
tempted not at all I'm not falling for
that totally transparent setup Annie are
you okay are you okay are you okay Annie
you and your corporation are
unequivocally unilaterally
unilaterally premature celebration for
the last half century you have been
feeding the American people the line
that your superheroes are chosen by God
and no one in the world thought it was
at all odd that God was only choosing to
bless American babies with a gift of
superpowers no one in the entire world
thought that that was unlikely they all
bought the yeah God did it [__] weird
I know but there we go wine
someone tell me what the hell's going on
watch just wait watch this instead of
just giving his boss the very urgent
headline this [__] will slow ball the
information and make her ask another
three times as if he knows he's building
to a big reveal at the end of an episode
of Television I haven't been using me to
get back at a train
no the answer is no of course I have a
nanny yes I bugged your phone but I
really like you and here's why I'm
trying to take down Vaught Huey does
nothing to help himself here and maybe
that's because he's overwhelmed with
guilt and he knows this isn't the whole
truth and just lets this question hang
so the show can have some more conflict
Huey has nothing to lose here and should
immediately be telling her all about VOD
and compound V I didn't ask for your
help yeah look like you had all under
control actually it kind of did he was
just explaining to Starlight why she
can't trust Vaude and should trust him
however I imagine what little
credibility Huey had might be undermined
now that he's running away from her with
the man who shot her why doesn't he stay
with Annie to prove that he's on her
side
[Music]
unequivocally unilaterally
you have one well I guess the look I'm
best known for is blue
it's blue what's that look like
so they thought it was you up there but
it was really Becca a bit deceptive in
there you pompous
scumbag face [__] [__] that
sounds wonderful thank you welcome to
the party pal I didn't realize there was
such a Cigar Aficionado
I don't smoke it's a disgusting habit
now let's see if you can defend yourself
you sweat from a baboon's balls yeah I
got it special 2016 Comic-Con edition
what do they make like a few hundred of
these
welcome Martini
[Music]
the Sea King will never know you you
tell him hi I tell him I will stay
not sure